here's how to land copyrighting clients
with zero experience and no cold DMS
number one read this book 10 times
number two is build a network of people
you would be interested in writing for
you can find them on Twitter you can
find them on LinkedIn number three after
you've built a relationship with some of
these people reach out to them and ask
them if you can write an email for them
number four prove that you can get them
results okay you send an email and you
actually make more sales than their last
email number five is you turn those
results into a case study before I wrote
this email for ex client they were
getting this much money in sales but
once I started writing email they were
getting this much money in sales number
six then ask that client for referrals
number seven make an offer to those
referrals repeat this process until you
close a couple clients and then increase
your prices as you increase your
portfolio here's how to land
copyrighting clients with